what's going on man so the young lady in
the car she s a cup so I haven't brought
out yet um she went in the building she
had a gun and a Pur okay she went in the
building with the gun I came over here I
asked the administrator was she in the
building with the bag and she said yes
how' you guys find out she had the gun
the security officer of my understanding
seen the gun seen it so and then um so I
went over there and I asked take the bag
off for her she said I Ain giving you my
gun so I said just take the bag off and
we'll talk about it and she was like I
ain't giving you my gun so then I I said
come here where you going she decided to
walk away so I grabbed her and I cuffed
her and I pulled the gun out of out of
her
bag didn't to no I didn't even say
nothing that even would make you think
that I was trying
to I didn't get a chance to get a purse
off because she already s up uh she was
she was giving me a hard time so I just
do her honor walk through in there just
to get the the back and separated from
the G yeah I haven't got a purse
yet cups too oh right
now come
on take your for you already got my gun
what do you need my purse for you took
my P look look relax stop I just got
arrested in front of my baby school if
this not the most embarrassing in a
school and I told them I had I didn't
Tak it and not tell them I informed them
cuz I walked my baby to school it's
illegal to bring it gun Ino and I tell
them I've come here every day there's
not nothing new we're going to go in our
car okay I'm not going nowhere well
we're going to have to rec cuff
you this is really
crazy you you a straight you came now
stop
nothing this some bro
like the I need my gun back when it's
all done and said with like did nothing
wrong I informed everybody and
everything like what I do this every day
turn
around don't put him on my wrist tight
he just did I just out bitch don't do
that TI I don't think you slipped out no
it was too tight on one and I told him
and I told him I was going to slip out
the other one because that other one was
so tight I told him before he did it and
he laughed at me like I
was this I can see if I came up here and
tried to hurt somebody I ain't come up
here to do nothing to nobody we'll talk
about it I for me you can go watch your
videos I don't even have to go
nowhere I specifically told them I have
my gun I didn't have to tell them I have
my fucking gun if I was trying to do
something to somebody that be clear that
would be stupid
onl
do you have anything else on you no I
didn't have no weapon in the first place
but my gun and I didn't come up here I
brought my baby to school and I told the
security guard like I got my gun
something I tell him every single day
I'm going do a quick p on with the back
of my hand all
right ridiculous is embarrassing my kid
school you have a CCW no I don't have no
CCW I'm able to carry without it yeah
you are I was just asking if you did
my I didn't take that they never seen it
I just told them man I had it because
I'm taking my baby inside to
school ledge victim um I could hear her
through the phone and they said as well
she appears to be heavily intoxicated as
well while on the phone with our RP so
I'm going to go and make
contact I got a shot fired shot
fired Alpha 52 Central there I just
heard a single gunshot from the
residence I'm trying to get into the
gate
[Music]
now
stay off the radio give me the
channel I made entry I'm trying to clear
the front there's lots of trailers and
barns it sound like it came from the
front of the
property more
Sheriff's Office show me your hands show
me your
hands put your hands up
now come out from the Drive come out
from the porch now Alpha 52 Central
challenging one come out to the
driveway slowly walk
out turn around face away from
me walk backwards to my
voice stop right there on your knees on
your knees lay down on your
stomach on your
[Applause]
stomach
Alpha 52 Central I've got one male
proned out in the front yard right in
front of the house when you come in
there's a barn to your left he's going
to be right in front of that Barn as you
walk around past it I've got him at
gunpoint on the ground put your hands
behind your
back yeah as you walk in the gate walk
around that Barn there and he's going to
be right in front of you as you walk
around the barn and just watch your
right I haven't cleared the right where
that Airstream motor home is or the
house yet either
whatever you do don't move if you try to
reach for anything or make any SED
movement I'll take that as a threat and
you could be shot you
understand who shot the
gun who shot the
gun I
okay I got coverer on the house he said
he shot the gun so there should be a
zero up here on the porch there's a
revolver on the porch right
there I've got two with me we're
securing the mail now and now we're
going to try and secure the residence
next
good
secure what's going
on my wife
is they rol right
here
upstairs want to
take got a revolver right
there on you share office anybody inside
come out now her
name's it's my wife we understand okay
where you
at are you
injured
come on to a dead end over here
guys it'll be a king
0210 583 I can't see I got too much dust
back here it's
1089 temp we're still going to be South
Sou
1089 guys 289 the grabble is really
slick and it's hard to see right
now passing 143 bu out down
[Music]
30 Road close sign, 1500
[Applause]
ft 4 24 to the unit that I directed to
stop if you can move out to the
section off
road
field
[Music]
she's heading back Northbound she's off
the road I see you underneath the
construction
equipment Lorden police show me empty
hands crawl
backwards crawl
backwards
get hands to St around
backward keep coming back come on you're
good